i'm thinking of a number
and you have
you have five guesses
to get it
is there a range oh yeah there's a range
it's between 1 and 20. 16.4
it's a whole number it's an integer
14. no
15
no
10 no
11
no
2
no
do i get any more guesses no
[Music]
i almost want like a greeting
and then instructions
and then i want to
basically it would be some kind of
input
input guess
and then we would want some kind of
feedback mechanism
i like it
perfect that's it we're done call it a
day so we could do something as simple
as
um
welcome
to our studios guess the
number
dame
putting a little comma
great
my brain is toast
okay
we need to tell them the
range eventually
i'm thinking of an integer between
a whole number
and you have a whole number between 1
and a 20
inclusive
[Music]
so i'm thinking of a whole number
between 1 and 20 inclusive
uh you have
i'm trying to think of the right number
of get let's well i think for us let's
do three guesses just so we're not
spending
yeah forever testing you have yeah three
guesses
two
three chances to guess the number
yes the number
uh enter your guests
in the box below
enter your guest in the box below and
hit the button
to see how you did
[Music]
okay we're gonna input in a guess
so we need
input
action
button
no i think it's just action button is it
okay
i like where you're going but
yeah i believe it's just action button
okay it didn't autofill and i got a
little nervous
all right input id
um so let's see
the action
button is going to be
oh that's that's
yeah submit
submit
submit and then the label will be
guess
yes
do it do it now
i'm going to be very aggressive
all right so we've got the button but we
didn't put in i say we as if i'm not
responsible for all of this
it's a text input so we need a
an input
it's a number though
numeric input
all right so
this is guess
is there a label yeah uh enter
your guess
here get my commas
oh because it's a numeric input
all right let's pull up the docs because
i can never remember all the arguments
so we can do our initial value is zero
we could do well no let's do our
can i do null
uh
i think it i think you can maybe uh but
min is one
and
oh yeah
let's also add in just to be explicit
step equals one so if they hit like the
up or down arrows it goes up by one
um
yeah let's see what happens
great
and then if you click and hit like up
arrow
then it like automatically starts
uh
this is a
old standing ide bug if you were to run
it in the browser your app worked as
expected but clicking that little button
is actually a bug in the ide all right
they're double submitting
got it
so i can override it
yeah
okay i mean oh and then our feedback
mechanism
um we will do something like
your guess
and was we kind of have two we're gonna
have three options right well four
options
because you're you're too low
you guessed the number you're too high
or you're out of guesses
so we can just do like uh
text output or
yeah text output and just label it
feedback
yeah
i don't know if it's input id
but no at least the first thing is is
the id so
what we need to connect here
is we need to connect
so our guess at some point is going to
need to be compared to the actual number
and then
i know that we're going to have some
kind of reactive here because you want
to so what seems logical to me is an
observe event
as in look for this button when this
button is pushed perform this action
and then based on that we're going to
get a feedback mechanism
so
the way i thought of this was where we
start with a number
um
and like we need our number
assigned so then we have the number
there's like the the app has picked a
number but then we also need to keep
track of the number of guesses that our
player is submitting and i believe
we did that as a reactive vowel
yes
because this changes given the
reactivity
a reactive valve versus just a counter
as a
regular r value
yes and we set that remember we set that
we gave it like an initial value of zero
i mean i i kind of want to go right into
the observe event does that
we don't assign this guy
to a variable
see if i remember how to type here so
what we're observing is our submit
button so
input
submit
[Music]
and then
yes yeah sorry input submit let's remove
the close curly on 35 and then it should
behave
all right great
perfect
rainbow
parentheses for the win
all right so we are observing basically
what we're saying here is like we're
keeping an eye on the input submit
button this guy labeled guess and then
when that is done
the guest needs to
increase the counter
yes
so we have a counter and i look i'm not
gonna lie i did not remember this i had
to look this up we had done
so there's like the counter
and then because your counter is a
reactive
you put in your counter with your open
parens
and then we increment it by one
yep add one and then to update the
counter value we submit it to the
counter function
and so we've done both the getter and
the setter in the same line
great so the counter has been
incremented cool so it makes sense to go
into like restricting the counter now
or to go inside
i think
it maybe after 31 we add in like
uh the guess because we don't want
all of our code to be changing as the
user changes the guest their their their
guess
um so we need like a resolved guess but
i like guess here
so it's also a reactive vowel
and then
after 36 after we've updated the counter
we can
set guess to be the input guess so on
submit we update the counter
yeah and we update
um the guess
yeah input dollar
is it yes yes
yes all right
we're not gonna uh should we name these
different no they're fine
it's fine and then that's
the
so the beginning of 37 will be guest
parentheses of input dollar gas
great and now we want to
basically we need a way to compare the
guess
to
number
and include our counter
let's yeah let's just work on all the
feedback
because that's something that's replaced
all right so we're going to get into our
little if else statements here which i'm
super excited about we call it counter
right so if our counter is greater than
three
so
that's when you've run out of guesses
so what
about this
all right so that's one condition
and before we go farther on this
this counter stuff let's put it
either as
uh the body of our render text for our
tech or feedback
or
a reactive of some kind
because counter is reactive
and then our render text
oh i'm gonna be so mad about this
formatting
this is where it's gonna go off the
rails
all right
right yeah and close friends yep
all right and our render text is going
to be our feedback
so yep the output
output dollar feedback
great so now the counter is executing in
a reactive context
so it's not it's not bad to write it as
you currently have where we have if with
an else and then inside the else section
we have an if with an else and then you
keep going because maybe they're they're
longer than just an if else
um but
if they kind of like tail off from one
to another then you can kind of just
merge the first if with the last elf
else
and um but it's clear if you write it
separately like we're doing right now so
let's go through like our numbers so if
you guess
um we can do if gas is less than number
then we're going to want to give some
feedback and the feedback whoops is
going to be
your
guess is too low and then
we would do an else if because we have
three conditions here right your
we have your guess can be too low we can
have your guess is going to be
[Music]
greater than
another
and then that's when we would want to
print
your guess is too high
[Music]
and then
we would have a remaining
else
yeah
winner winner chicken dinner
so and while it is valid code may we
move 47 up into 46
just so
thank you
no problem
all right so we've done a bunch of code
so let's
run it and
perfect i have an argument length
of zero so my guess is i'm getting that
because there is no i haven't given it a
guess
uh most likely yep so let's see what
happens yeah
stop
let's double check
okay hey he just happened to have
received it hey
what are the odds
that like well one in 20.
what so i there are two things that i'm
noticing that i'd like to fix let's just
reload this guy right so this error
argument
is of length zero is that something so i
want to fix that and then i would
actually really like to fix
um if you guess the number like the game
exits out
the guess the number exit let's hold
that for a little bit because we'll just
worry about the feedback mechanism for
now argument of length zero so you said
because you didn't have a guess
right
so what is the trick that we use to
prevent
render methods from erroring
but like reactivity is still there
what method do we use i really hope the
answer is wreck
because that is
because
mostly because i want to say you have to
check yourself before you wreck yourself
i'm embarrassed for myself right now
all right so
what we want here is we want input guess
uh
not necessarily we want wait no
guess itself
because
you can type all you want
but i don't want it to you don't want to
submit feedback until
oh
okay so actually it's the input submit
button
but input or sorry guess parentheses is
not updated until input submit is
updated so
at this point
uh if we wreck guess they're on line 41
then we know the counter is okay because
it's defaulted to zero but on 45
it is
like that's where it's actually required
so this is good um
and guess and counter both get updated
on submit
so we don't necessarily need to do
we i mean to be safe we could also do a
wreck uh counter and the same like you
can do it in the same line or
multiple lines
um can i do this
yes yeah
and
uh it's i mean that's that's good then
that way all your reactives have true
must have truthy values meaning that
your counter is at least one
and your guess is not like
missing
so let's see if this fixes the bug
wreck to the rescue
perfect love it
and wreck is a silent exit and so it
just means don't do anything
and so there's no feedback displayed
which is what we want everything seems
to be working what would you say is next
is it handling the exit yeah let's do
that okay
handling the exit trying to think of a
quick one here because there's nothing
like stop game
um
i mean we can kill the shiny app i know
that
uh
[Laughter]
and then there's an animation that's
like
confetti
you know and and all of that but i feel
like that's maybe
next
call
i mean we could have the tab panels here
where we just
we we remove input guess and just hide
it
and
say refresh the page or something like
that so would i just put
my whole input section inside of a tab
set panel
okay so my input section is here
and so inside tap zip panel we need a
tab panel body
yes
um
but we'll we'll have the h1 inside it
have a little body
just do a little copy paste job here
it'll be fine
and
yeah and all of that as well yep
great
and then the first argument to the tab
panel body is its uh
name
so we can call it
um
guest module
i don't want to use the word module yet
how about we'll do a guest panel
yeah and the let's for the tab set panel
let's also add an id equals
um
so this is going to be
like our
um
guessing area
i don't know something like that yeah i
appreciate you not wanting to use
modules because that is a very specific
thing in shiny
so even though i'm thinking of this like
a module i think yeah guessing area
seems a little vague but
i don't you're right we should not call
it a guessing module
oh yeah the tab set panel we need to say
because there you ran the app and
there's like a pill at the top
um so we want to say type equals hidden
yeah it's a programmatic way
so then
we got rid of that horizontal rule we
got rid of the tab
you don't know it's there oh and are you
thinking of putting the feedback in a
tab set panel that we can also hide
um so that it only pops up
after you guess or am i completely
misreading that
uh maybe
so maybe i was trying to go too too
small with the idea maybe we we go with
your original approach where the whole
screen goes you guessed it
awesome or you ran out of guesses we're
done
and that's it
so it's like the whole game and then
that way when you go back to the
beginning then we can kind of reset
everything
like you don't need a greeting and
instructions when you can't do anything
yeah yeah so you're saying
what i do
i can just put the feedback mechanism in
its own tab panel body correct or would
it go in a whole new tab set panel
uh no let's just put it in the um
in like right after 2028
so it's just like our we're going to put
the whole former ui into one panel
so let's actually grab the greeting and
the instructions from above and put this
inside
i love how this has suddenly become
like
it's now integrated what we did in the
previous one let's move um
9 to 13 inside the tab panel body right
beneath it oh yeah yeah
okay
great and this should work just as is
because we've essentially taken our
whole previous application and put it in
a tab with a hidden nav bar
and like everything will work just fine
um
yeah just
nothing is really going to happen here
so
observe event part
um
let's
let's go ahead and add the
this idea and here's where we can since
we're familiar with this
we can take a stab in the dark on what
it should be and we may not see it until
it we connect the wire
okay
so let's go back up to the ui and let's
just add in two more tab panel bodies
okay um
and you can do them here or above either
one um
maybe we do it as the
maybe we do it above so that we can at
least see it like in line eight and then
we might move it below
um
or add in a
parameter later so this one is going to
be like
uh
so guest panel like correct panel and
incorrect panel
would be the two names
uh so we had i'm sorry you literally
just said that like correct panel don't
listen to any of that
yeah
i heard it i did not ingest anything so
we had guest panel and correct panel
uh
incorrect panel maybe or wrong panel
uh
great and then because we already have
guest pin on on seventeen
and then equals two right
uh the type hidden is already done on
seven so it's uh this is now just like
the body of it so let's just add in an
h1 of like
your number's wrong and that's it like
or you guessed incorrectly
yeah
chicken dinner
and
not chicken dinner
put it in
quotes hang on
hang on
here we go
great um
so this is now we can update the panel
when our um
tab panel body value must be a single
non-empty string
um let's not title it id on 10 and 15
because i think the correct key is like
value or something weird that's not
not what
makes sense
they win we automatically win
yes
and if we just for fun if we switch
correct panel on incorrect panel or we
say let's just go ahead and do this one
how about after line seven say selected
equals
incorrect panel
great
wrong
and just to make sure guest panel is
still there we can just add that in for
selected
oh yeah i love that so this is we wanted
to avoid this in the last one because it
would have been a bunch of debugging but
now we're kind of figuring out placement
so this is fun to work on yeah and our
game is still here
i love that and this is this is our
starting screen as well so we can
actually leave the selected there so
it's not just a
debugging ourselves let's go back to
that observe event
my favorite
i actually really like observe event for
some reason that one just clicks with me
so
it
it really does um this is a so observe
is wonderful for side effects
um
we can do this all in one observe event
but
mentally i kind of think of this as like
when do we go to these final screens
right so to me it's an extra observe
event
okay
um
so what are we observing in this case
uh the counter is too big
right
so if the counter is too big
uh
yeah so
uh counters so we'll say if counter is
greater than three and then we'll also
then we want to do what is it update tab
set panel
um
with the session
is fine input id equals
and we'll have to label it yeah input id
equals what is it guess area what did we
call it at the top
between the two of us
we're gonna get this uh i
guess panel
guess
the top top
top guessing area guessing area c
guessing area
and the new value is um
we could we could send them to wrong
right
and this is the value i can't remember
value equals um incorrect
incorrect panel
panel
so
let's try this see what
happens oh okay cool um so observe event
this is expert is missing observe event
needs a listen to this and then perform
that
yeah so you said hey go do this thing
but that's not what observe event wants
so we should listen to counter
uh but yeah keep going
then i start curly
oh yes thank you i was like it's
it's somewhere
there we go great so this
uh yeah kill and restart yeah
okay so now if i just do
value is the incorrect mean name
so let's
look at update
select the update oh selected not
not value but selected
all right
okay so we'll give it a one and we'll
guess three times one right well here
i'll change it just just you know
all right that was three guesses now
when i it's yes when i do the fourth
guess
wrong
[Laughter]
i don't know why i like that so much but
i love it
all right that's great so
would this now be a situation where i've
got my first
if
and can i
i don't want to be like just
but would it just be
else
well would i want all three conditions
in here uh no it's like so this isn't
necessarily towards the guess we've
actually handled the
73 and 74
because that will never be touched
anymore
as
if you hit if you run out of guesses we
now go to the wrong page
um yeah
so we can actually remove that if you
want
from the app
so we can get rid of these
and 80.
thank you you're so good at spotting
it's practice on practice
i love it so now i feel like we've made
it we've added functionality we've made
it a little more efficient
we broke it
i mean broke it
all right
so we have removed
our because we're handling our counter
we've removed it from our if else
statement so at this point do we
add an else and then
we would only need an else for um
sending them to the correct
answer
yeah so we could do
i mean you could
this is where it's like it comes down to
a little bit of like style and how you
want to do it
so we can have the single observe event
be like handling uh
like sending you to the place
uh the flip side is like this is a
observing the counter and when the
counter changes if it's bigger than
three then we go somewhere
but um
maybe we want to do like observe event
of guess
and if guess is
uh
um yeah of the guess and given the guess
we'll do another
uh curly outside um yep
and
we'll now say if
um yes double equals
number
then
update tab set panel correct
okay
good
oh maybe the clothes on 79
or
78 one of them
great
um so theoretically if we scroll down
just a little bit
the feedback of 88 will never be touched
or it will it will be touched but it
will never be displayed
wouldn't it be displayed for if your
guess is too low or your guess is too
high
correct but not 88.
okay so we could get rid of this
if
correct
and yeah this guy
uh-huh
it is equivalent um
yeah
i love it all right good
uh oh but we still have the rule there
on 85 so it needs to be an else if
um or just plain house with no guesses
greater than number that's right okay
so if we say
10
it's too high
five it's too high
two
and now there's there's a weird behavior
here because at this point
i'm entering a fourth guess
and it's letting me guess
um
so
if that's the case then i think we
should combine our observe events
okay so these when you're talking about
combining observe events
you're 21 and
all right so if counter is
greater than three
okay so that the if logic is still good
but maybe at
68 it's now an elsif
guess double equals number
and you can just take your logic from 73
like verbatim
and then we'll get rid of this guy
need everybody to calm down on the
formatting we're going to figure it out
maybe
close parens after 71 add a closed paren
after 71 oh okay
great
no
oh we have
if argument is of length zero
oh uh remember from before we needed to
wreck guess
yeah so
leaf
i'll go ahead
oh perfectly fine to do in
63
if we want to do it there
so
wait you're saying
like where in 63 would i put a wrecked
gas inside the
curly brace
uh
before the if
got it so i would do
[Music]
wreck
guess
and then
elaine and then we're good
all right
oh i broke everything
there we go
perfect
have we done it
i think it's pretty close yeah you low
so we'll do 15. it's too high
it was wrong
[Music]